- Yeah, so there's
been a very big moment
in my life recently.
I just moved to New York
City a couple months ago.
Woo.
(audience cheers)
Yeah, it's truly been just okay.
(laughs)
(audience laughing)
Ah, god, New York is
the place I live now.
I realized pretty
early on, moving there,
that because I'm a pretty
safe-looking black man,
that strangers
love talking to me.
(audience laughing)
And I was on the train
talking to this one woman,
just having small
talk and she asked me
where was I from originally.
And I was like "Oh, the
south side of Chicago."
And then I did some
poses, so like yes,
yes,
(audience laughing)
and she replied "Oh
my god, I'm so sorry."
(audience laughing)
And I was like,
well damn, bitch,
you have strong opinions.
(laughs)
(audience laughing)
And then she leaned in
closer and she asked
"Have you ever been shot?"
(audience laughing)
And I replied "First of all,
have you no couth, white devil?"
(laughs)
(audience laughing)
We just met.
(laughs)
(audience laughing)
How would you feel if I
asked where are your lips?
(laughs)
(audience laughing)
Then, second of all,
no, I have not been shot
and I think that's a
very shitty stereotype
that perpetuates the idea
that Chicago is a
very violent place.
So I wanna say right now, in
front of all of you that, yes,
I was born and raised on
the south side of Chicago
and I have never been shot.
Thank you so much, I'm a hero.
Thank you.
(audience cheering)
I have been shot at, though,
but they missed every time.
(laughs)
(audience laughing)
I'm a fucking gazelle.
(laughs)
(audience laughing)
Ho, jacket's coming off.
Shit's fittin' to
get real, okay?
(laughs)
(audience laughing)
My feelings about Chicago
are pretty unique.
Like, as a black
man, I love Chicago.
I would defend it to the end.
As a gay man, that place can
suck a bag of dicks and die.
Fuck Chicago.
(laughs)
(audience laughing)
It is trash.
It could burn to
the ground again.
(laughs)
(audience laughing)
And it's funny, 'cause
I think Chicago's
the reason why I'm
as gay as I am.
Like, was I born gay?
Maybe.
(laughs)
(audience laughing)
I came out of my mother's
vagina and I was like,
oh my god, what is this?
(audience laughing)
What the fuck?
But then the doctor smacked my
ass and I was like, mhmmhmm.
Ah, okay daddy.
(laughs)
(audience laughing)
Let's see where this goes.
(laughs)
(audience laughing)
I realized that I was
gay at a pretty young age
but also realized that,
within certain environments,
it was not okay to be gay.
So I was in the closet
for quite a bit of time.
And I remember the exact moment
my gayness was solidified.
I was dating this
girl named Raven.
I hope she not here.
(laughs)
(audience laughing)
And it was the day that
I lost my virginity.
We went to her grandparent's
house, 'cause we're edgy.
And,
(audience laughing)
we got there, took off our
clothes, put on some music.
I asked if it could be
Celine Dion, she said no.
(audience laughing)
Then I started to
smash that cat.
And,
(audience laughing)
it was great.
It was going well.
She was looking at me,
I was looking at a
picture of her father.
(audience laughing)
And then she was like,
let's raise the stakes.
And I was like, please don't.
And she was like,
hey, go down on me.
And I was like, for
sure, I love a challenge.
So (laughs)
(audience laughing)
I go down there and, ladies,
it is complex down there.
And I didn't really
know what I was doing,
so I just started experimenting.
So I slapped it a little bit
(audience laughing)
Blew inside of it.
Counted the rings to
see how old it was.
(audience laughing)
And she was like, no,
silly, use your tongue.
And I was like, oh my god,
thank you for the tip.
So,
(audience laughing)
I proceed to place my tongue
somewhere I can only describe
as texturally unsettling.
(audience laughing)
It had the texture
of, like, a flan.
(audience laughing)
or, like a tres leches cake.
Very moist, very spongy.
But it tastes like
a bag of nickels.
(audience laughing)
And I was like, oh
my god, I'm gay.
Oh my god, uh, uh.
(audience laughing)
But I couldn't tell her that
'cause I was so in the closet.
So I was just like, oh
my god, I'm so full.
I can't have another bite.
(laughs)
(audience laughing)
And I never did.